solo sonrisas entre los negociadores del
partido socialista por el acuerdo
francia en su misa el histórico pacto es
un intento de impedir que el presidente
manuel marco obtenga la mayoría en el
parlamento pero el acuerdo podría
provocar la implosión de uno de los
partidos tradicionales de francia ante
las críticas de antiguos dirigentes
el secretario del partido lo defendió no
me he convertido repentinamente en la
francia y sumisa lo que pienso lo
seguiré pensando sería una completa
locura pasar de esto y pensar que porque
tenemos desacuerdos no podemos gobernar
juntos pienso exactamente lo contrario
según olivia fue esta unión es la única
forma de salvar el partido uno que lleva
casi una década en una espiral
descendente desde la victoria de
françois hollande en 2012 hasta el 17 de
anne hidalgo sólo han pasado 10 años
hidalgo ha criticado el acuerdo pero ha
dicho que no quiere interponerse en su
camino para otras figuras del partido la
unión es impensable ni con solo ni su ex
primer ministro bernat kushner respaldan
el acuerdo uno de los principales puntos
de fricción era europa el partido
socialista apartarse temporalmente de
las normas de la unión europea mientras
que francia en su misa dice estar
dispuesta a desobedecer las el acuerdo
ofrece 70 escaños al partido socialista
con la esperanza de ganar unos 30